when you think about the constraints on
a sodoku grid and I obviously there's
the famous one you've got to have one to
nine in these rows columns and but this
is another constraint on a sodoku it's
amazing that so many are possible it's
amazing they can make so many different
ones oh yeah the the world of sodoku um
it's almost a sort of bottomless pit
we've just done the fist of Mel ring and
we saw how sets of different digits can
be important I'm going to show you
something mad now which is where soku
constructed have taken this sort of
thinking I don't know if you can see
this this grid here but there's a few
things to know about the the rules of
sodoku as they apply in this grid so you
can see there are some cages in the
grid so the digits in this cage have to
sum to Y to the power of two the digits
in this cage have to sum to X to the^
two and the only other thing you really
need to know is that these see these
arrows with circles the digits along the
arrow row have to sum up to the digit in
the circle so if this was a one and this
was a two this would be equal to three
this puzzle involved trying to work out
what X and Y were and using the fistel
ring and the ideas of set theory you can
work it out and that's what I'll try and
show you now it also has to obey the
normal sidoku rules of the columns the
rows and the squares yes it does it does
indeed let me start so this time we're
going to highlight the first four row of
the grid using the red pen and again we
know that the the red cells are four
sets of the digits 1 to n Al together
and now our green cells this time are
not going to be quite the same so we I'm
going to highlight five complete columns
so in this instance we've got four sets
of the digits 1 to9 in the red cells and
five sets of the digits 1 to N9 in the
green columns and we can see if we look
carefully again let's use my blue pen
this portion of the
grid has two colors in every cell so we
can remove all of these from both sets
and we know that the difference between
the red set of tiles and the green set
of tiles is still one set of the digits
1 to n because we had four sets versus
five sets we've removed the same thing
from both so the difference is still one
set of the digits 1 to 9 I want to
imagine the we remove this box one this
box here from the red set so now what's
the difference between the red tiles
we've got remaining and the green tiles
we've got remaining is now two sets of
the digits 1 to n so we're going into
mad mad lands now but we can actually
use this to solve this puzzle because
what we've got remaining in red is just
this cage which we know sums to Y to
the^ of two and what we've got left in
the bottom of the grid is all all of
those squares so it's all of these
squares versus this cage the difference
is two sets of the digits 1 to N9 and
this is where Constructors get even more
crazy because they say okay well what
would happen if we
equalized those differences so what we
could do is add the whole of column
9 into
red and what we could do is add the
whole of row nine into
red and if we did that this cell is
obviously twice in red now this cell
here but if we do that red and green are
now equivalent again because we've added
one complete set one more complete set
of red into into the red set and another
complete row of the stoku that's another
complete set of the digits 1 to n into
the red set so at the moment the red and
the green are now equivalent and now you
can play some games to isolate
this cage which I hopefully you can see
is X to the^ of two and the way that you
do that is you take out just as we did
before you take out the cells from both
sets that are common which is this
one this one this one this one this one
this one this one and this
one and if you look very carefully now
you can see that these arrows which have
to add up to the same number these two
digits here sum up to the same as a
digit in the green set so if we were to
take these two digits out of red and
take this digit out of green the sets
still should sum to the same number we
can take these two out and knock this
one out and look at the what we're left
in the corner we've got this cell here
which was twice in red and once in green
so if we cancel that once from red and
once from Green we end up with it being
once in red and it cancels out with its
Arrow here like that and we now have an
equation where we have proved that what
is left in red is exactly equal to what
is left in
green and this is the difference of
squares because you can see that x ^ 2
is
equal to y ^ 2 + x + y from these cages
and that allows you if you you can solve
that
equation and you'll find out that X and
Y differ by exactly one and that allows
you to solve the
puzzle
simple not not simple but actually once
you start to understand
fistel achievable and quite magical and
the thing I really love about this
puzzle is the puzzle title was
difference of
squares and it results in a mathematical
difference of squares being the equation
but that equation is derived from what
we did at the start which was to find
the different the geometric difference
of squares in the grid so sort of the
title is hinting at the geometry and
hinting at the maths involved it's
really beautiful Simon did the person
who set this puzzle realize this was the
way it could be solved or was there
other other ways to do it yeah this was
set by math
guy2 uh who is a mathematician uh I
think that they doing a PhD in number
Theory and they wanted to set a puzzle
that could explain to a Layman about the
difference of squares and they achieved
it in this sort of magic magical way uh
it's the first puzzle I believe they've
ever set so it's it's quite an
incredible debut you couldn't but you
couldn't solve this like people on the
train by putting does a one work there
does a two no I I invite you to try
would tell I think I don't think you
could get through it you maybe if you
gave yourself a hundred years and you
guessed a lot you could do it by
iteration but it wouldn't be
fun if you haven't already seen it I'll
include a link below to our video with
Simon about the mysterious fist
ring there'll also be links to Simon and
his mate Mark's YouTube channel cracking
the cryptic if you haven't already seen
it I think you might like
it take all the possible sidoka grids
and check all of them for 16 clue
starting positions and to check if they
give you a unique answer that's that's
one way to do it it's a Brute Force way
to do it how many ways are I to pick 16
clues from my doku grid